folks
oops yeah we're good um I have not been
live today
because I had an appointment in the
morning and then I had to spend a whole
bunch of hours doing micro code updates
on our
cluster which was not very
fun and I'm pretty
tired but I figured I'd hop on just for
a little bit
and uh take a look at some
stuff so our
experiments oops our experiments seem to
have gone very
blinding we already have 14,000 cont
track things in
Neptune a lot of those are just the
synthetic test that are pretty
quick
um but you can see
here we've
got
they where is it there is very nice Pito
front on Breakout
we've
got a very nice burrito front on
one we've got a very nice parito front
on
Palm it's pretty interesting that for
all of these environments it's kind of
like a straight
front you
know you kind of wonder that there
should be some curve
here of
sorts uh but I think what's happened is
it's just it's figured out essentially
the fastest parameters and it's solving
it with the fastest
parameters more or
less yeah 20 million so actually that
might mean that um
it could be
possible to reduce the total num time
steps though interestingly it's not like
finding a solution with one update Epoch
or anything or more Ms so maybe not
maybe not we'll do more work on this but
for now I think we're just going to keep
running all of these uh
various
experiments we going to queue up a few
of these tonight
and uh probably do a little bit of
work on just
improving carbs generally improving the
code I don't know if I really want to
start on that now it's a pretty big task
I've only got about an
hour I don't think what I can do right
now that would be like
interesting you kind of want to like
review a PR or some code like an
environment merge that sort of thing
let's see if anybody's around for
not that bad to
update there we
go silly that you need to manually
update it like that but
whatever I'm sure he doesn't know that
this s by default
MH let's see if bets around for a final
Enduro
review would be good
good let's look at what M we want to do
next
um there are a couple things I want to
do here actually
that there there's one actually there is
one thing I want to do here I thought up
why my overlays not
work
view it's very
obnoxious well I'll just go grab the
ream
browser uh where is it
there we go welcome YouTube
folks now I can actually see
this yeah so the one thing I wanted to
do here that I kind of realized
well I should do uh hang on I should
actually test this
properly I'll show you what this is
about in a
five
maybe and then we'll just average
still quite a bit of
variance we'll do it over
10 let's try this for
20 there we go so for YouTube folks that
just
joined um we're doing some additional
tests on the new neoc carbs hyper
parameter sweep algorithm that seems to
be doing incredibly incredibly well we
have uh we've got purrito front's 200
experiment curves on pong very good
result there on Enduro we have a very
good result here and also on breakout
very good result here so we've got lots
of nice
experiments um and what I'm doing here
at the moment is I just want to make
sure that the scale of the search ranges
for these very
parameters is going to be compatible
with a random surf so you're going to be
able to use the same parameters for
carbs and uh for random search and if
I'm looking at this
here yeah I
believe that I've doubled
these so now the question is is this
actually a good thing that I double the
so if I do is it if I just do this and I
get rid of these we're not going to like
close the fall we'll keep them around
how do we
worse way way worse okay that's quite
interesting so can we actually do better
with a tighter
bound let's
see I do two
five
let's see if this does
five let's see if this does better I don't necessarily have any
better I don't necessarily have any
reason to expect it will but uh the goal
should be that we
have the same set of hyper parameters or
the same set of meta parameters I guess
cuz they're sweet parameters
oh dang does this actually do
better tighter bound does actually seem
to do better
interesting though I think it's because
the uh the initial parameters are pretty
darn close to
the the initial parameters are actually
really close to the optimal ones the
mean
I don't think we're going to count that
too highly for this but what we are
going to do at the very least um since I
was doubling all these
parameters in the other
trials uh what we are going to
do Global so we have this Global search
SK we're just going to set this to
one uh and that should have the effect
let me make sure it's actually being
used
Global so we have this search
distribution in basic and has this
global
scale and what that's going to let us do
is it's going to let us use all these
nice hyper
let me just check what the time
step this has a 0.5 on it and then this.
25.5 2 five yes so the rest of these got
doubled uh the Palm
one is at
5 I think that's actually 0.25 now
right that's
0.25 so hopefully I don't mess anything
up
here but this should
be. 25
now but then the rest of these
0.511 one
one.5
oops you can see these are
or is it 25.5 so these are all
half which
means that I can just delete them
all because now we've adjusted the scale
the only thing that matters is this
unique per environment total time steps
parameter and and what we're going to do
is we're going to clean this up that
way okay I got to go grab the breakout
frames off the server real
quick just did brand
new
oops just did uh micro code updates on
all these today so they should be more
stable
hopefully so breakout config and the
only thing that we care about here is
this parameter
which we're going to do this to the
scale goes to.
25 we are set uh we also have
be so this is not a bad config
right and this is pretty pretty easy to
set per environment
now uh so we're going to set this for
our two new environments that we're
going to test right
now be
is these prems look good for
snake or 200 mil time step environment
this is pretty
good this should be perfectly fine
uh this doesn't take numb
ends and it
take oh okay so this doesn't take num
M's that's a bit of a
it it's a little tricky the way it's set
up
maybe we'll leave snake for later I
don't have too long right now so I'll do
the environments that are easier to uh
to
configure we'll do
you see that there are all these janky
parameters
around time step is 100
million I think we're going to
do 5 E7 to
start 5
E7 I guess we'll do 5 E7 to start and
then this will go up
to uh 2 E8
welcome I think 57 will be
fine but you know intuitively it doesn't
seem to me like it should take that long
to
solve able do like
this something like this you
know I don't want to set it too
low okay so we'll do
this do all of that
we'll do trash pickup we'll be at one
for the
sweep and then we'll
do uh I think rware should be
cool this has no
mouse and then this is I think this is
175 mil but again I don't believe that
it should be that long we'll set the max
at
38 Min will be
here and then we'll set this one
e
h actually I think I'll set this one E8
as well so we'll set the means a little
higher so this is
us I I think that this will probably be
sufficient I think it should
be
so all we got to do is we add in we just
uh Commit This
it
ho and we will set up our
slower probably are
whereare what I missed pretty solid
hyper PR sweep
algorithm um that we're now in the
testing stage of so I'm currently I'm
going to set up two 200 experiment
sweeps one on a remote server one on
this local box and we will continue
testing
these
um I think that they both Define
score I
think do they both Define score I guess
we'll see in a
moment I should probably test
l oh I think it's
um yeah it's how quickly you can solve
it or whatever
that ideally we would like to have all
the score functions for all of our
environments nicely normalized and
clean um
where's our Vector
ar oh I guess I don't have that on this
Branch yet do
I that's fine
like okay so this needs a score function
for sure
I'm just going to add
one that's very silly for them to not
have
fine okay so we'll do log score equals
graph collected -
0.1
time so
L we'll just do this for
now that'll give us a consistent score
function
um we need something like this in order
to be able to
to run our
sweeps and I don't think that
the the current thing was very
good know all these environments will
continue to be tweaked over the uh the
coming months they're not final by any
means we're not we're really way more
focused on pushing RL forward than like
standardizing benchmarks or something
and currently it seems like the way to
push things forward is to be more fast
and
flexible that's what we're going to
do let's make sure that we have a
score okay there's still no score so
that leads me whoops that leads me to
believe that something screwy is uh
going want in the scyon
correctly that's pretty weird it did the
logs
correctly
a trash
collected Aggregate and
clear return log uh I the only thing I
could think about is yeah right here
float
SC it's very small scon
thing the intermediate layer with
scyon as its pros and cons
I initially liked it as like a way to
like a soft Landing to get people into
lower level
code but
um I don't
know I'm kind of thinking now that it's
better to just rip that Band-Aid right
this yeah there's no way that this thing
is going to take
I think we're going to find a set of
hyper prams that train this in like 30
mil or
something which is what I have it set to
so this is
fine okay so here on this
Neptune last me for my
token which will just leak because who
this
oops we actually want a team up
mods and now we
have 2 million steps per second worth of
experiments running
machines
and if we give this just a
tag neoc carbs
rware and we'll tag
this neoc
carbs
CRA pick
up and
now this one goes in background this one
stays on my local machine in the for
round and we go
to we Group
tags and now we
have our nice new experiments
so here we have our score we have our
cost this appears to be getting logged
correctly and this appears to get be
getting logged
correctly so I mean those seem to
be 2minute experiments or
so so this entire process should be a
few hours
for these two uh
environments and assuming that this
works then you know we'll have nice Bas
lines and we'll move on to the next ones
and we'll you know we'll continue
cleaning up and making sure everything
has a consistent score
function uh we'll move on to probably
maybe we'll do like triple Triad and
Connect Four just to finish up the
simpler environments we'll fix up snake
go tactics need some work still
um and then we'll do the two big ones Mo
mo3 and by then maybe we'll have a few
more environments merged in and that
will be our initial set of baselines
with our new
algorithm uh and then we will run some
comparisons
against vanilla carbs I
suppose before I started messing with
it
and we will see how well uh it does I'm
not sure if I want to write up a full
paper on this like papers are such a
waste of time blog posts are much better
I'm at the very least going to do a blog
post on
least and workshop papers don't even
really do anything for me either I don't
know we'll see
I'm very interested to see how it does
on the harder
Ms you know cuz well MOBA to be fair you
can kind of just discover a not that
complicated policy that does pretty well
and not that
long neural MMO 3 will be a real test
though that's a hard environment very
hard
environment so we'll see we'll see how
it goes
um I mean that's the main thing I wanted
to do for now to discuss the plans going
forward I'm going to do a couple things
on stream for various academic labs and
clients over the course of this week uh
I'm also going to probably carve out at
least a day for myself to work on
rewriting the carbs
code Maybe not maybe once I have the
experiments I'll clean it up we'll see
um but that is going to happen I'm not
going to leave the carbs cod as is I'm
going to very much clean it up um it's
still based on the original code from
mbw they did a great job with the
algorithm that the code could use some
work we're going to clean that all up
nicely probably ship it with puffer uh
just as a you know bundled thing we'll
see um and what
else I'm leaving for a little trip on
Friday not a very long trip I'll be gone
for you know a few days um but before
then you know we're going to get a a
fair bit of cool stuff done I'd say
there's some stuff to do on GPU Drive
nyu's GPU accelerated driving Sim
they're generally doing pretty well
since I you know I made everything nice
and fast they're running some nice hyper
parameter sweeps I might integrate this
for them we'll see I've got a thing with
Kathy wo's lab where they've given me
some feedback and I need to do a couple
things for them maybe will'll do that
tomorrow then I've got a couple client
things to do on um some stuff on
exploration work and some stuff on uh
Robotics and bindings for puffer so
we'll look at
that I think I still have a few minutes
here I got to go to dinner in a second
but I have a few minutes um I'm trying
to think what other small things we can
do right now that would be interesting
happy to answer any questions people
have if people are looking for help
getting started or port or
anything oh did I
[Music]
finish perfect so maybe we'll start
looking at this until uh until dinner
it's there we
go so 11 minutes
ago we'll review his code this is a
pretty cool environment so um you've
probably seen me do this a couple times
and have this weird icon up here so uh
Spencer implemented
a a version of a puzzle
game uh tower climbing puzzle game 3D
game it's pretty
cool and take a look at what he's done
here can I just pull
this well I have this these experiments
running now so maybe not but we will
look at the code
start with
his
config see what he
said
okay he's got some rewards that have
been clearly tuned this is good this is
a good number of Ms it's got two full
day
synchronicity ah you want me to look at
your policy we'll do that in a second
mini batch looks good batch size looks
good pretty high entropy coefficient but
this if this is what tuning found then
sure yeah Lambda yeah this is about what
I'd expect learning rate's
fine uh I wouldn't suggest tuning these
Spencer I'd kind of just leave these
ones at default because if you let the
algorithm tune these it can do weird
things but these look like good settings
that it's
found yeah
okay and now you want to look at was it
ocean
good this should not be terribly
complicated of a
policy and it isn't perfect so we we
have a 3D version of my net uh
ooh
twos y
twos why have you done
9 the whole game is 5X 5 by9 all the
different levels
well I'm
surprised 5x5 is pretty small what's the
nine which direction is the nine is the
nine
up okay the whatever X is is that
horizontal is that up what is it
I'm trying to
think can you solve the game only seeing
two up or do you you have it centered
above the player though don't
player centered one below the
player how does that make any sense he
can only see one one row
up you can literally only see one row up
if you do
all right based on playing the game you
need to be able to see a few rows up one
above okay okay if it's one above then
you can see three okay that's
better 2 by two coms can be kind of
sketchy cuz they're like they're not
this isn't going to be centered on the
player is the thing you actually like
when you Comal this you don't get
anything centered on the
player so I would test both because this
might be
sketchy flat sized is
16 by
what is this
number yeah try three with stride one
just run the oblation right it's a quick
oblation to
run um this is 9 *
7 is 63 * 16
is I don't know roughly a th000 a little
less kind of
okay I think 3x3 brings this down to 1
by 1 by five at the
sure and then you'd be able to up um com
you'd be able to increase the Inn
channels to 32 as well because it would
be 32 * 7 which will be reasonable
number or 32 * 5 which is a reasonable
number we'll see if that slows the
policy down
but okay you got a
flat actually gets crazy close to
beating level
two well training
on the prams that just beat level one
okay let's see so we got flat if you
write some sort of random level
generation it's going to work way
better and actually that'll be cool
because I can introduce you to all sorts
of cool curriculum learning
people um I know a lot of people in that
space or a few good people at least in
that space we got flat which is 4 to
16 we got PR
honestly I don't even know if you need
this
layer you could just concatenate the
features raw here if you're going to do
this layer though don't use 16 16 is not
a good number for um for linear layers
in neural Nets you kind of get away with
it with comp Channels cuz like you have
more weights than just the 16 but 16 is
where you start getting into things like
local Optima in search space 32 is a
bare minimum I would make it like
64 or
128 yeah don't ever don't put 16s here
you can do it in com channels because
like a com is actually a 3D block of
weights right 16 by kernel by kernel by
whatever something output or something
um so like don't worry about that but
yeah this is this is where you start
getting into numerical problems like in
optimization space and where you start
hearing horrifying things about local
Optima so I would not suggest
this you might not even need this to be
honest you could just concatenate it
straight to here it might be a decent
idea to have it though you could try
both
um actually a cute thing that you could
do here would be
if you make this what is what did I say
7 by so this will be 5 and
32 okay then what you could do is 3 * 32
is 96 you could put this to
96 and then does that
work 256 perfect and then you don't even
need the projection layer at all and you
can just put it straight into the lstm
so you'd save the pro layer and keep
this layer could be
good sometimes you want to re after this
sometimes you
don't okay this is a reasonable little
Network though other than the 16 there's
nothing that's like straight up
bad twos Maybe a little sketchy nothing
straight up bad though does this thing
fast 650k not
bad and I assume your network
bound what happened here in trash pickup
has one item
oh I think this is an
[Music]
working all right
so yeah the stuff I told you would maybe
increase network speed a little I mean
would decrease network speed a little
bit so maybe not amazing I don't
know okay something is very silly with
this end and
Ms does this have a score yeah it does
very nice this does have a score should
be nice and easy
reward question so I got hold on let me
move this so I can
read right now the goal isn't always the
highest point and yet I give a reward
for climbing
I mean I would stop giving it rewards
above the goal and then add a plus one
for the goal is what I would
do just like stop giving it rewards
above the goal and add a plus one for
the
all right tripal Triad how the hell does
it take 200 million steps for you to
solve triple
do what we
do 57 1
E8 need 1 E9 it can have like I don't
know
this we'll see if this is
good so I give you your total time steps
pram and then we will
yeah solving a distribution of levels
could have a different set of hyper
parameters I don't think you want to
like go find a different set of hyper
parameters for each individual level
though I think what you'd rather do is
you'd rather have a bunch of levels
maybe PCG levels whatever and solve the
distribution here's your triple Triad m
we're now using this as a
benchmark hopefully
uh you can solve
it I don't know what's the best as you
can technically do at
anyways we got 14 points so far for
rware
none of these seem to be doing
particularly
amazing it'll be interesting to see how
it does over
time it's pushing the total time steps
down a little too low
maybe I mean it's going to do that we'll
see we talk about PCD for a second do
you think a path verifier is hard it
just modified breath first with legal
moves
um yeah it's a little annoying because
like you can you can change the state so
you'll probably need to have state
changes you'll probably need to have
like Fast State sets which if you have
the state in an array is just a mem
copy um so that could be a little bit
tricky but otherwise yeah it's just uh
breath for search over
actions because there's no Randomness
it's
deterministic you could even do AAR if
you
want that's just a a very simple
heuristic addition to breath ver
search the thing is that you don't need
to do this at um train time right you
just you can just make a file to
generate 10,000 levels right and you can
run this thing you can can maybe compute
a couple Statistics over them for
difficulty right like you can compute
the number of moves
required uh you can compute yeah the
number of moves required actually breath
for search is good for that you can
compute the number of moves required to
solve
it and I mean that'll give you you can
do some nice curriculum stuff with that
like I literally was just talking to
somebody about having a maze environment
in puffer like a basic 3D ma uh 2D maze
environment and they have they're going
to implement this they have it in like a
grid engine of theirs and I'm probably
going to do a couple things on that for
them so like this is a little bit more
complicated than that but the premise is
very similar and this would be a very
nice environment for doing curriculum
learning type work I it's kind of
similar to any of the puzzle LMS right
like people use soab ban a bunch for uh
for RL people have used you know grid
type maze environments people have used
like all sorts of things like that
anything you can PCG over cleanly is uh
is pretty
good and make sure that your triple
Triad end is running and then I think
it's dinner
a tanky Chopper hey good to see
you whoops let's move this out of the
way I don't know what's up with all
these M's not Ealing this is kind of
weird arcade levels get pretty hard
curriculum could be pretty
relevant it figures out pretty complex
techniques early
on yeah I mean a good curriculum can
really just help you Auto solve stuff um
and the funny thing about that is like
just a Rand like randomly presenting
levels is the naiv form of curriculum
and I wouldn't be surprised if with how
fast your m is that already helps like
that might just already be
enough okay this is the second
environment that's stuck in an eval Loop
um I'm a bit confused as to why that is
the case
I do try to require it to eval quite a
few games but it's been stuck for a
here this need multiprocessing on it at
all maybe it's the multiprocessing
somehow
mli
[Music]
A7 do like this for you
see about
this so a 10K levels what is best
logging best
completed
tracking well you're not going to track
progress
individually um
I mean you can
check yeah you can check the total
number of levels unique level solved you
can check like
the uh you can check like the max num
moves or whatever of level solved there
are lots of metrics you can come up with
to see how it's progressing
if this one gets stuck I'm going to be
very
confused it's allowed to take a little
bit of time here because it's we require
a very uh a very good eval
estimate in order
to we basically require it to return a
large number of evaluations so that we
can make sure that we're actually
getting good data back but it seems like
it's getting stuck on all like some of
the M are getting stuck
levels one solv and only 15 yeah it's
great and I bet you I bet you you can go
even faster than that once we do carbs
on it neoc
carbs this algorithm is very very
good if you want to help with it figure
out why these hems don't freaking
work what specs do you have on the
machines most of the machines they have
either 13 9900ks or 14 9900ks
uh so you know 24 cor Intel chips
basically best Intel chip you can buy in
a desktop and uh 4090 is in them they're
pretty nice
machines in fact I got a little write up
about the cluster here there's some nice
posts here like uh this where is it no
not here yeah there this is the
cluster yes we were I just spent most of
today doing bios updates on these and
one of these boxes is dead and is
getting rade for a bad
chip all of our new boxes will be AMD
the box that I'm currently on the
desktop I'm on right now is a test
machine that has a 16 core AMD 99 50x
and a 4090 and then when we actually go
to buy the real cluster the real cluster
is going to be 40 machines uh with 509s
and 950x is 128 gigs of
RAM it'll be very
nice we'll basically have as much
computers we'll
need yeah these are all getting stuck
Spencer I have no idea
why but they're all getting stuck
it's very
weird you get stuck on evaluation for
some
know I can't really think of why they
would
no no no not visualization we run uh we
basically we do train eval train eval
right eval train eval train is the loop
not roll out just eval uh and what we do
is at the end of training we run eval a
bunch in order to collect steps so we
get a really good estimate of the
score and
uh yeah it's not working for some of
these M for some reasons we have to do
some work on
that I got to run to dinner in a second
here but uh we do have a fair number of
folks watching at the moment we actually
peaked at 10 a couple minutes ago which
is pretty cool to get back to that um
but for folks here I stream a lot of
reinforcement learning Dev pretty much
all the stuff I do on puffer you can
learn more about the project at puffer
doai it's all open source you can
actually play some of these environments
all of our environments really and watch
reinforcement learning agents play them
they're all listed right here
we've got docss we've got some nice cool
blog stuff on here other's stuff for
companies but again it's all open source
and you can check out the code if you
want to help us out for free just start
the repository trying to grow the
project it really
helps you can join the Discord 900
people in here hacking on awesome RL
stuff uh if you're trying to get into RL
or if you're trying to get into H perf
RL one of the best things you can do is
just build a new RL environment from
scratch go through the process of
getting it into puffer lib it's really
great way to get into the stuff and you
can also follow me on X where I post
pretty much just all reinforcement
learning content and there are a couple
articles here as well that aren't on the
uh puffer site in case you're interested
some of my more out there
stuff still I'm learning though it'd be
no help right now you'd be surprised you
just keep the stuff that you work on
simple and you do it well
right a fair bit of stuff you can do
I've trained a lot of people in here as
well you know um via like all like I do
so many code reviews right people pretty
quickly get the hang of stuff it's kind
of a good way to
learn I mean Spencer came in without RL
experience and built one
two three was it four environments four
environments
now was on a fifth one um bet did Enduro
we had two different people do breakout
in
pong right somebody did tactics so
somebody's working on Robo code now same
guy that did breakouts working on this
so there's lots of cool
stuff I'll know one obscure fact and
then I'll not even yeah that's generally
what you're like your uh your F first
University course in CS is for is for
like rounding out all the dumb basic
stuff that you somehow missed I would
suggest uh I mean you don't have to wait
until you get to University
right I'd suggest this one this is their
like this is basically the course that
you would take if you went to Stanford
as uh a freshman who has like been
coding for a few years but missed some
fundamentals this is the good one to
take
this is pretty much the only course I
really suggest to take like the courses
very quickly diminish in value after you
go after you take the um the intro stuff
but this is like this rounds out a bunch
of stuff C++ is a terrible language but
you know
whatever I hate C++ I really hate C++
God it's awes
awful why well it's a terribly designed
language it's just a whole bunch of
stuff bolted on to
see thanks for the policy review I'll
see how that doesn't work on either plg
or you can onboard me to science while I
run sweeps
awesome I really would like to have some
help on the science side you know it
would be it would be nice for people to
be doing you know fixing up M's for
sweeps you know start like getting
involved in running the sweeps getting
involved Captain's doing the continuous
stuff well one small one very small
thing at the moment bet I'm trying these
on the ablation branch and if you check
like I think triple Triad Connect
4 um
and what else oh yeah trash was it trash
pickup uh none of them seem to run with
sweeps they seem to get stuck at eval at
the end of
training Captain's almost done with it I
think it's a pretty small
update Enduro runs oh yeah bet I'll show
you this and then I'll hop off um here's
Enduro I think we kind of solved
Enduro so
in 5 minutes we get uh less than 5
minutes we
have 11,000 Spore or
whatever real
quick uh I'm going to go get dinner man
at 7 I'll be around though I'll be
around either later or all week pretty
much
so yeah time for dinner um yeah I'll
show you this last chart
bet okay score should not be arbitrary
that should be the metric that you can
rely on that is all of the puffer M
should have a score metric that you can
rely on uh but if you must know
[Music]
passing
30,000 is 10,000
cars yeah these plots are laggy I like
my dashboard
better all right folks yeah I'm hopping
off for now I might be back later I
might do a later evening stream I don't
know it's kind of late already uh I
might F though uh but anyways please
just start the repository really helps
me out and check out the Discord you
know we'd love to have more people
contributing to the project you don't
need RL experience you just need to be
know a decent programmer and uh be
willing to learn some stuff that's about
it working hard on eat healthy I do eat
pretty I eat pretty darn healthy I think
I'm
[Music]
doing I just started the blueprint
supplements today I've got uh I don't
know like turkey big bowl of peas and uh
some rice that's pretty basic stuff